is currently champ two playing six man's
in this replay review and says i think
two of my biggest issues are one i don't
look for passes enough too i try to do
too much with the ball which causes too
many solo plays and overuses a boost i
feel my defensive position isn't the
best and causes a lot of goals i mainly
am just curious in the replay what
situations i should be passing in
because i struggle to recognize when and
how i should pass
the replay is of six man's game but i
think it has been missing passing
opportunities i'm hoping you'll help me
spot
i think i have the ability to hit gc i
just don't use my teammates enough man
interesting this guy wants to be a team
player kinda like that
okay okay dude
so i see why he submitted this replay
it's because in the first
15 seconds this guy hits a ridiculous
shot holy [ __ ]
damn
okay man
great shot
really looking out for a pass there
right good defensive rotation
ask your boy
so there was a great passing opportunity
that you executed perfectly and your
teammate missed it
that is not your fault
i wonder if he thinks some of these are
his fault because that was a perfect
nice controlled slow pass right to his
buoyancy
now again chad if you don't know what
six man's is you have to be in coms to
play six man's
so all of these guys are communicating
to each other so probably the gameplay
is gonna look a lot better
than
ranked usually does i'm not i'm not
gonna lie chat this is two minutes in
and i have literally no gripe with
anything he's doing look at all the
space you have you literally did it in
the first play of the game
where you hit an unbelievably good shot
i know you don't have as many as much
boost here
but this
is just giving away possession take
possession every [ __ ] time you guys
get it i don't care how much boost you
have if you have open space and you can
catch the ball
please do stop hitting it to the other
end for no reason
thanks
polar is not playing well i i'm gonna
say that real quick polar is going for
the side boost
polar is cutting you off basically in
this rotation because he should be
holding the right side of the field and
you're holding mid to left side of the
field and he just cuts right in front of
you does it does a dog [ __ ] flick or
flip
toward the play that he can't get
polar cut you off
and it led to a goal now
when you see this you backed off
and you went for a good shadow
defensive play here bake it
bake challenge this and just drive back
to net rotate wide back yep instead he
does this he tries to block it which
never works
90 of the time it doesn't work
and then
yeah
guys if you ever find yourself in a
situation like this where your last back
your third man
you're getting cut off by your boys
just
fake challenge
right here you got both your teammates
not where they're supposed to be
fake challenge waste time
that should be the only thought going
through your brain
waste time
don't commit to nothing when you're
third man that's not high percentage
when you throw yourself at a play that
you have a very low percent of
low percent chance of hitting okay
my man did you miss a boost and turn
around
chat what do we do when we miss a big
boost you just keep swimming swimming
swimming just keep swimming
but you don't [ __ ] back up for it
dawg
is that like while your teammates are
doing some dumb stupid [ __ ] here
you gotta play your role you gotta play
you gotta do what you gotta do stay in
the flow of the play or this happens
and it's pain
look look at
al qaeda here
[Music]
which meat is saying that's probably
gonna get me banned somewhere but look
at him he's sitting still
he's out of this game
and when you're playing six mance if you
have one player who's upset it's over
because they're likely 14 years old and
they have no competitive integrity
whatsoever if they are not winning by 15
then they're sad depressed
and they will uh give up
i need my participation trophy now
it's not my fault
i need my participation good try on the
possession here you guys see this
so
what a lot of lower ranked players do in
this situation guys is they boom this
ball as hard as they can at the wall and
then it centers for the other team
so
volteer didn't do a perfect job but he
didn't boom it into the wall
he kind of tapped it could have done a
better job mechanically with that
but it was good he's made a couple of
decision-making errors but nothing that
he was saying like i need to work on my
passing or anything like that
um okay so let's look at this
let's take it let's take a gander just
looking at this situation
should bolt here go for this ball the
reason he shouldn't
is that even before he jumps you got
erwick on the wall
at wick
who's definitely gonna go for this
axles jumps too
so when you have the other team double
committee
you don't go
you
let them make that mistake and then you
take advantage of that mistake you going
for this is allowing their double commit
to be okay
because then you won't be in the play
i'm pretty sure all three of you missed
the ball well eric axel's hit hits it or
whatever
so all this stuff like you would have
had a better play on the ball if you
just didn't go for it just let him hit
it and then take possession instead of
you having to rotate back now and get
boost you could be in this play
with your team instead you have to
rotate out and get boosts and stuff so
that's how you avoid that situation
completely
it's just off one mistake that you
really don't think about too much in
game
nothing wrong mechanically there he just
you know he did everything he could
it's a decision
good try look at this pass too
this was spicy
look at this
i like that
and this too
take a look at where turkey is probably
not getting a goal here
what do you think is the better play
here chad he passes this ball mid oh man
it's a goal 99
but bolt here is thinking of passes
constantly i think he just thought he
had an open net and went for it and
that's totally fine vulture definitely
does not have a problem passing in fact
his passing is very good i think there's
mostly with volteer decision making
errors but a lot of what he's doing is
solid very good everything defensively
is easier from the backboard and if you
practice it it's even easier obviously
but even when someone controls it you
can dive on top of them really good
defensive positioning there if they flip
it over the net like happens here if
you're on the wall already right here
this clear is definitely not so bad but
when you have to jump straight up
defensively
that leads to bad stuff so i think
boltier
his kind of his reaction
to things happening is a tad bit slow
and his decision making is slightly
slightly off but
is very mechanically gifted you guys get
in the same read as me like
very good nothing wrong with his
rotations i think he thinks of the past
and he has great passes when he was
telling us that he's he thinks he could
be a better passer i don't think that's
true at all you know your decision
making could be a bit quicker i want to
know how this game ends because it
should have ended right [ __ ] there
nice
third time
in the last three minutes of this game
bolts here wouldn't have done this you
let this ball hit your car bro and you
take control of this look at this
this ball is going right to you you pop
this you pop this ball right up in the
air dude you go for your nice air
dribble because you clearly are a great
aerial specialist you do this
because it's over time and we're
panicking now yeah there's definitely
some bad stuff his teammates are doing
but we're we're analyzing him we're
analyzing bolts here here you guys were
playing so good and then overtime hit
and everything went out the window
because we're nervous now we're scared
this whole situation is avoided if you
pop this ball up and go for an air
dribble
this is giving the ball to the other
team i know you didn't mean to hit it
this week but
that was the play 100 percent
flat panic
they didn't even score yet
holy [ __ ] the game didn't end there
either you guys should have lost twice
by now they should have lost twice
absolutely by this point if you have one
player in the corner
don't go in the corner
or one player on your if you have one
player on your team
in the corner
don't join them your teammate are in a
bad position
and the ball goes over your head
and then you panic pass
right to the middle of the field
and to the other team
and you get lucky you can hit it again
but now
you have low boost so this whole
situation is working out that you're not
getting scored on
yet
a lot of players don't think ahead now
you have 10 boost you're out of position
polar's clearly out of position this is
not a good situation this is what leads
to a goal is all this stuff happening
so while you haven't been scored on yet
i could tell you're pretty damn close
but yet again
right here is night and day from what
you were doing at the beginning of the
match when you were scoring and had
control right here
take possession of the ball do not hit
it away from yourself
stop it and keeda has to bail you out
which he didn't even have to do
doesn't work doesn't do it
and the game ends this goal happened
because you gave away possession and
then your teammate missed and then
poller's in the wrong spot we're
reviewing you bolt here okay
you're in the wrong spot and you made
the wrong decision to hit the ball away
from yourself instead of control it that
is your biggest issue in my opinion you
hit the ball away from yourself when you
don't need to which is completely the
opposite of the first half of the match
look at look at bull tears first goal
chat he waits he's playing back playing
patient
ball goes up keeps it to himself
controls it to himself
gets the nasty flip reset
boom double tap easy goal and in the
second half of the game you played a
completely different game don't fix what
ain't broken dog keep doing that stuff
he stopped taking possession when he had
the chances in the second half of the
match
and for you that's why you started
playing poorly in the second half of the
match
and it's why you lost now could your
teammates could have done a lot better
but again we're not analyzing them we're
analyzing you it was immediate right off
the kickoff after his beautiful goal
takes possession
takes his time
keeps it close passes it mid to his team
outplaying two people and then he
completely stopped doing that don't
change it up because you have a lead
okay a lot of players do that and it
leads to a lot of
a lot of losses when you don't need to
take them okay
so
keep possession as much as you can bolt
here because you started giving it away
absolutely and i think you'll just
you'll soar through the ranks you'll
play much better there's nothing wrong
with your passing like you said in your
um
in your replay archives said you wanted
to working on wanted to work on your
passing your passing's great you need to
work on your decision making which is
slightly slow you could be a bit quicker
to your decisions than actually
executing them
and then keeping possession of the ball
which you're clearly good at but you
didn't do consistently throughout the
entire game and i think if you focus on
that you're gonna find that the game
gets a lot easier and you're gonna
you're gonna play your game
more often